and one of the things I really really
like to do in when I was trying to learn
how all the pieces move and to do what I
called obstacle courses obstacle courses
all these were so much fun
and my teacher would set up all kinds of
weird situations where I had to be very
very clever
like really really really clever and the
idea of the obstacle courses is that
black does not move white is just making
all the moves he wants and black cannot
respond black just watches what white is
doing and the idea of the obstacle
course was to capture as many as much of
as as much material as possible and we
did the material count you all know that
the Queen's worth nine the rook is worth
five the pawns are worth one the night
at the bishops are worth three so in
this situation white is on turn and what
white is trying to do is figure out what
piece he should promote to he could
belong to a queen a rook a bishop a
knight not a king you can never promote
a pawn to the king or a pond you can't
keep the pawn as a pawn when it's
promoted so what you guys have got to
figure out is what would be a good piece
to promote to that's number one and
secondly how you would capture as much
material as possible there is other
rules to an obstacle course the moment
that you
put your piece in capture so the moment
let's say that white promotes to a
bishop and white takes this pawn
well the moment you put your piece and
capture your turns over and then you've
got to add up how many you how many
things that you captured so in this
position for example you you have to
think ahead you have to think ahead and
if you say to yourself the piece that
captures the Queen well the moment that
piece captures the Queen the pawn is
going to be able to capture that piece
as well so your turns up and then you've
got to add up how much material you
captured yes young man what would you do
yes please and an obstacle course we
just put any material we want it's not
like we're playing a game of chess what
we're trying to do is just make puzzles
yes young man what would you do
no it's that you can use as many moves
as you want you can move as many losses
you want yes you know check no because
in terms of a check that would that
would mean that black would have to
respond and then your turn is over okay
so what you're trying to do is capture
as many of black's pieces as possible if
you give a check or if you put your
piece and capture your turns over okay
yes young man what do you think promote
and then to what what would you a queen
okay so first of all let me remember the
position and let me find a white queen
so first of all we're gonna we're gonna
do what we call a marker somebody is
going to to show us their solution and
then we're going to count what they did
so this young man go ahead get a queen
and show us what you would do how many
moves you would play go ahead you've got
a queen by the way how many of you would
make the Queen as well well how would
you go about capturing blacks so first
of all you would want to take this rook
if you take the pawn the rook takes your
queen and that would be the end of your
turn you didn't even make them go here
and take the rook queen c8 Bravo
continue okay so the first point is he
has how many okay good
continue continue you've got five you're
gonna be our markers Oh careful careful
the pawn is protected the pawn is
protected anywhere anywhere you like go
ahead
okay now he's up to six that's pretty
good
continue continue yeah well aha your
turns going to be over it will be a
check okay bravo Bravo now he has wow
seven continue take as many mixes and
pick as much as you can check will end
your turn and leaving your queen and
capture well and your turn yes so you
could take this pawn but then that's the
end of your turn
you could take this pawn that's the end
of your turn or you could take that pawn
and that's the end of your turn okay
bravo Bravo
thank you okay we have our marker yes
what did he do five eight so now now we
have our marker someone has managed to
capture eight eight that's pretty good
that's actually that's real good but can
anybody beat that young man in the back
yes with the glasses come on up show us
how you would be eight that's our marker
your go oh he didn't wanna you're gonna
use a night thank you
okay that's one but although that's six
that's pretty good
six he's thinking about that was the
solution nobody is going to be able to
be rook five queen nine 14 15 16 17 and
the problem with the knight was that you
you didn't you couldn't your turn would
have ended if you taken the pawn or be
exactly right exactly
okay wonderful you did great so let's
say he had made a bishop because what he
was saying and he's absolutely right is
the bishop could take a lot of stuff
right the bishop could have made five
the bishop could have made six the
bishop could have made seven but the
bishop could never attack the Queen the
bishop could never attack that part or
that one so the best that the bishop
could do is to take that pawn and that
would have only been which was the same
as the marker the first person who who
who gave us a goal that we have to beat
okay
did you like that obstacle course you'd
like me to make another one okay all
right let me make another obstacle
course
so in this obstacle course if you
noticed I've given white upon as well as
a king
so in this obstacle course what you're
trying to do is you're trying to capture
as many
of blacks pieces as possible you want
the big big big material number and you
can use your pawn if you can you can
promote your pawn if you can promote
your pawn so you're so black is not
going to make any moves neither any
moves at all
but if you give black a check your turns
over and if you leave your piece
encapture then your turns over as well
so do you want to give it a shot then
okay what could you do he did our marker
did 15 which is huge that's there's no
way you can beat that number let's give
it a try one bravo Bravo Bravo okay you
remember what the marker did that was
pretty clever yes yes Ari ends up five
okay now now what did you do oh very
good clever to eliminate the rook and
Bishop right away eight yes Bravo
nine so far so good you did everything
that our marker has done okay and now
and now keep going keep going what what
would you like to promote a knight whoo
was that good yeah you like that okay
yes okay you did good cheese you guys
are doing it really great
okay he did it really really good I
can't believe it
now remember that Jack finishes a turn
and and when you leave your piece in yes
okay and now what's the idea now what
are you going to do okay just a second
there okay so far is he's in the rules
everything is okay ah did that end
because it's a it's protected so that
would be the end of your turn you match
the marker you match the marker okay a
big applause yeah that was that was a
different a different I think just a
second before before I choose the next
one I think REM played it perfectly to
this situation okay okay come on young
man what would yes yeah what would you
do
he played it perfectly to this situation
but then he made a mistake he went for
the night what could he have done
instead
that's a check everybody knows the
solution you guys can see it okay okay
okay
Bravo did you see that
Oh high five well done applause
everybody that was it okay now what was
the marker 15 okay nine fourteen
fourteen seventeen seventeen wow that
was pretty good twenty-one